this is my thesis designing game ethics
a pervasive adaptation of The Count of
Monte Cristo so for one week in January
2007 15 players participated in the play
test of an adaptation of The Count of
Monte Cristo gameplay ran around the
clock for seven days and took place
throughout my key campus sibility sought
to transform the players everyday campus
environment into an imaginary 19th
century Paris on the eve of Napoleon
Saturdays its ability involved roll
thing work each player took on one of
these roles characters were identified
by their French monograms and these are
the 15 player rolls which included a
banker a judge a DBA a sailor a Duke I
ship owner a soldier and a servant for
each other's breath before the game
started players received an initial game
packet it's included the rules a
character briefing sheet a clear map in
a gang insignia to wear on their person
whenever they were playing players
started up not being introduced to one
another at the start of the game but
slowly met each other as the week went
on and in-game events in public spaces
around campus each player was also given
a dead drop it was hidden somewhere I
did what was basically a small
tupperware box that stuff could be put
into we hit several underneath benches
my personal favorite was the dead drop
belonging to a come to monday to get at
this dead drop you have to find the
right Locker and have the right
combination the primary game mechanic in
civitate involved first receiving
documents and objects in their dead
drops including the copy of the category
christo all documents included
information about a secret plot line
such as a scandalous love affair or on
desicrew movements or secret political
affiliations those had to decide what to
do with the documents they received we
could pass them on to another
dead drop or share them new person or
keep them fizzles let's started out
knowing about only a few dead drops they
could discover new ones by listening to
audio promenade which were basically
podcasts that describe the game world
and give hints to each location and this
is an audio promenade slip which has
some instructions and a URL requires to
download by collecting and listening to
the audio common odds players to find
all of the dead drop locations this is
the game masters cheat sheet with all of
the dead drops players are asked to
email a daily report to the game master
a siege evening that described their
actions that they took the each day and
why they chose to do them in the morning
players receive news about the game roll
through the gossip rag website this
included narrative descriptions about
what's going on and also display the
badges for the players are in through
their gameplay the day before we are
comforted with a variety of ethical
choices such as whom to share the
information with since each piece of
information could potentially damage
another player's reputation the badges
recognized ratings of ethical behaviors
here in the bottom right corner you can
see the beef and the st. Patty's so I'm
using the guilty carts argument about
ethics and games to organize my thesis
into roughly two parts the first part
revolves around game designers and the
ethics involved in designing games games
are ethical systems that are embedded
with their designers ethical values
intentional or otherwise in the game
design process we spent a lot of time
afton game mechanics that engage players
and ethical and unethical behavior and
encourage at the co reflection I'm not
gonna be focusing so much on this part
in this presentation what I am going to
talk about it is the second part which
has to do with players and
and how they interact with gains as
designed ethical systems players are
moral agents that activate the potential
choices that game designers created the
potential choices that game designers
have created in their games this means
that there's think about ethics they
bring their own ethical systems into the
games they play and they respond and
react to ethics in use in the January
play test of civility thurs wrote about
many ethical choices and issues in their
daily reports they talked about them at
the group debriefing and they talked to
me about them in individual interviews
that I did with them after the game is
over I've organized these issues into
three ethical domains raging from the
ethics of stealing from the gamemaster's
to mitigating to the epics of making
assumptions or asking clarifying
questions frames took a variety of
positions on each ethical issue on a
wide spectrum of possibilities the first
is the procedural domain which has to do
with ethical issues with regard to rules
the second one has to is this mentok
demand which has to do with ethical
issues in the context of the game and
the third is the Magic Circle to talk
about the magic circles domain I'm going
to quickly talk about what it is what is
the matter so keep scholars Katie salen
and eric zimmerman define the magic
circle as the idea of a special place
and time and space created by game so
basically it's a metaphorical boundary
between that encloses and separates
games from everyday life and ethical
issues in the medical and the magic
circles the main are ones that are
related to that boundary or to the
context in which games are played to
better explain these ethical domains I'm
going to illustrate each domain with one
or two examples from civic
I I wanted also first come out that
there are going to be using photos from
the play test in each of the upcoming
slides and that the players shown them
are not the players important for issues
of privacy and also due to time
constraints I'm not going to talk about
the photos right now and tell you what's
going on under how they're related to
the ethical domain I'm talking about but
you can ask me about them in the queue
for now just lift the photos remind you
that each of the ethical issues that i'm
going to be talking about actually took
place during the game the first is the
procedural main in civility we
intentionally designed a degree of
ambiguity into the rules of the game
with two bowls in mind the first goal
was to my players to consider the
various possibilities that each
ambiguous rule offered thereby creating
ethical dilemmas the second goal was to
simulate the time period that was in
heavy political turmoil in which legal
actions taken a one day were overturned
and we go on on the next something is
clearly understood and saw these aims
the Silva expressed in his interview
when you have a game that's designed in
this kind of setting with these kinds of
holes and the rules my assumption is
that you want some people to be doing
some of these things and not doing some
of these days I did get the sense that
the rules were meant to be morally gray
because the world is gray one of the
rules that we intentionally included
ambiguity involved when players could
visit their own dead cops and when they
could visit dead jobs that belong to
other players in the rules we have
remained each day before 2pm you may
visit your dead drop and retrieve any
documents that have been provided
anonymous way to you each day after 2pm
you may visit their jobs that have been
arranged for other citizens to pass
along the information you have received
this has been carefully worded so that
first be free to interpret the ethical
occasions different this offer is clear
choices and forces players to reflect on
the ethics of each possible choice by
intentionally using the optional may we
hope to encourage players to question
this volume of printer again we were
seeking to emulate turbulent
revolutionary times in which the rules
constantly shifted and ethical behavior
was constantly challenged i look at your
first day of gameplay a parking garage
mucinous daily report it occurs to me
that well to Kim is a rather clear break
between the picking up and dropping off
of information the boundary on the other
end is less better shall I begin to
check my box only after dawn or should I
take the upper hand and check the night
videos examining boxes before their
contents have been withdrawn by their
intended recipients immoral conduct it
also occurs to me that perhaps I was
intended to wait until two came today to
find the other in drop boxes on my
promenade given that not everything had
been withdrawn yet if so that is
assuming and certainly when I would not
follow the necessity that I know the
true goings-on in the same he sweetly
decided as early as the first day of
then regardless of the official role
he's going to visit other players dead
drops before too in order to keep
himself probably for a loop fair
differed on how they dealt the before to
after to issue this is clearly an
ethical issue that has to do with the
rules as compared to the semantic domain
in this domain and people issues have to
do with the context of the game world in
civility the semantics context contains
the ethical issues that players were
represented from their character's
perspective in relation to the fictional
19th century Parisian world one of the
ethical issues that fares contended with
was the degree to which they were
playing in character in other words the
degree to which they were making
decisions from the perspective of
character role they were this issue
takes into account the pre prescribed
character identities that me the game
designers had composed for each
character role this is the character
briefing sheet for the domestic
philadelphia's we attempted to compose
the character briefings for each
character as someone suggested sketches
of a character's past rather than a
portrait of their motivations or desires
but the mystic villa dr us grow quite
elegantly about her thoughts and
feelings in her daily reports on the
second day of game 50 I'm a loyal
servant I figured my character will
probably do anything she can to help her
mistress out of any sticky situation of
Canadian this early reflection on her
character's relationship to a dr.s
guided her subsequent actions in the
game I'm afforded the same claim she
describes how she dealt with a
particular ethical issue that arose she
wrote I'm ashamed to admit it but I took
the letter from the gendarmerie slobs I
love the note telling of the writer
suspicions of love today's but without
evidence I do not know what I took the
letter in a moment of panic because it
makes reference to the lady knowing my
mistress to be friends with the Duke I
worried that she might be caught up in
this and I wish to avoid damage to her
reputation on the next day she wrote
this afternoon I attended the party at
the Cathedral for among other things I
learned that the lady referred to in the
know a vigil number his box it's more
likely to be the socialite than my
mistress so in the interest of justice I
replaced the note in this daily reports
she expresses that she feels shame for
stealing a document from Montgomery her
actions are guided not by whether
stealing from an MPC is allowed in the
rules or not but by what she feels her
character would do in this situation
another ethical issue that or so we've
had to do with the specific actions they
could do when interacting with
we design game mechanics that would
prompt players to consider it lying
spying stealing and sabotaging one
another and in the process hopefully
considerate the ethical implications of
these actions within the semantic
context of civility and also in the
larger everyday life context in which
civility was seen play some flares had
no ethical problems with taking these
kinds of actions but others like the
doctors felt differently she wrote upon
these travels I discovered a package
from a prepared to rock I was tempted to
open it but I cannot bring myself to
open another's mail no matter how juicy
the secrets within might be so these are
ethical issues affairs Dhawan's again
within the context of the game as
compared to the Magic Circle swimming
there's concern about ethical issues in
the magic circles domain are concerned
about the ethical consequences of
actions in the context of everyday life
as lammeter app we put it unless the
gameplay extended into the real world
and real psychological places I didn't
see anything that's being truly moral or
email in Cebu tape players consistently
articulated that they were afraid of
ruining another player's game fight or
ruining other players fun they also
voice that they were afraid of breaking
a game or ruining my research to players
who allied with one another during the
game and who were also friends before
games like can I use this dimension to
explicitly determine what they
considered ethical and the preferred
darasa that he judged whether he would
do something by whether it would
interfere with other players play on the
third day of the game with social i
wrote i didn't feel bad about stealing
the directions from their return until
the proper dorado me that he would feel
bad about it i realized that i might be
interfering with clara Turks gameplay
and that could make the game was fun for
him as a result of this conversation she
asks what prepared raw to return the
things yet stolen to the two of their
terror on her
my original research question was how
does one design a game to make change
and now this is an incredibly fraud
question so it was refined to how can i
define how can I design a game that in
cages players an ethical game the pre of
cool domains that I identified from the
play test provide game designers some
ways to think about ethics as they
design cakes designing free testing and
reflecting on civility as part of a lot
of further questions that would be
really exciting to explore some of these
include have you exchanged for games
that use different game so how do i
exchange on PC games console games card
games or games mmorpgs how do game
ethics change four games in different
genres so to know it was a historical
fiction about science fiction and
fantasy still so on and what sorts of
ethical game issues come up in other
pervasive games vs sevilla tape which is
a one very specific design I'd like to
conclude by the other game designers who
worked on civility these are the full
credits which appear on the civil it a
website to all of these wonderful people
and to all of the wonderful players who
participated in the Fate test
yeah so the process of designing that's
originally started with me thinking
about doing an adaptation to a digital
game for so little experience and
choosing to do a pervasive game was part
of my design process where it was
influenced by another pervasive thing
that I had designed that there will be
in this direction I think that pervasive
games were a really interesting tool to
use six more epochs because they blur
the boundary between everyday life and
the game world and they changed the way
that fires think about ethics and that
was one of the questions I was really
trying to investigate it is how do do
players feel differently are there
different pressures that experience when
the game is taking place in their
everyday apart when there are audience
members walking through
I think
more how the modulus is not
that night um so see if I can get to
okay my boon is my food what is a
pervasive thing and Marcus contoured
defines a pervasive game as a game that
has one or more salient features that
expands the contractual and Magic Circle
plays spatially and temporally and so if
certainly civility doesn't have a very
fixed Magic Circle and I have some signs
show how it breaks each of those
dimensions the first is spatially it
took place around MIT campus in research
areas in hallways that are not designed
game play spaces this is a gathering in
which there's some players on the ground
floor talking and discussing documents
that they perceive and then there's this
clear up here was spying on them and
they don't know that he's there it also
changed it also attended on the temporal
dimension in that game ran around the
clock it was it was hard for players to
it wasn't like okay now the game is on
how they thought I'm going to sit down
and play and now I'm going to get up and
do my the rest of my life of course some
of the players did very clearly
delineate I'm sitting aside this time
within my day to placate other players
would be walking around canvas and just
be like oh I want to go do this thing
now even though it's in the middle of my
day I didn't plan it he saw this is one
of the in-game events that took place in
seven that was in the middle of the day
and then the last one is the social
dimension where it has two until it
describes us as the talking about who
are the participants in the game and in
most games you have the players and then
you have people who are not playing the
game in all players some some games you
have sectors and so on but usually it's
the game is made of
in our game we we purposely put it in
public spaces to try and engage with
this um the with the public and in place
every day people walking through campus
as citizens of parents and some prayers
did articulate I did feel like the
people walking through made the space
seemed more like a bustling city this is
one of Game Masters masquerading at the
player and in that same event this is
the game master and this is a tourist
taking a picture ok so the this the
social dimension can range from directly
engaging non-players into a gameplay for
moments or temporarily to spectatorship
as I question about the ambiguity of the
rule so so we played the game I know
that a very prominent feature among
people were playing was the fact the
rules like you had mentioned were sort
of intentionally ambiguous and that for
some people that weren't very
experienced with masive games this kind
of thing that was a very frustrating
it's very internet this wasn't as well
I bother me as much but it seems like
basically don't necessarily have to go
hand in hand with ambiguous rules and
that they would in book ethical
decisions and ethical dilemmas
regardless of whether or not the rules
were ambiguous so I'm curious just to
hear your thoughts about that about what
you think would have happened if you had
had a game that had more concrete rules
or what really has certainly um so
definitely ambiguous rules is not
necessarily tied to pervasive games the
I have identified those in my visas as
two separate tools that were deployed in
civility as a series of strip some a
subset of the series of strategies and
tactics that we use when designing the
game to engage players and ethical and
unethical behavior and ethical
reflection in because rules was a
difficult one and one that I'm not sure
having done the play test I would
necessarily recommend because it was
actually one of the game mechanics that
was very frustrating requires and I
think that one one way that that could
have been mitigated was if when we were
asked about the Bulls that room because
that's when the ambiguity stops because
now you ask the authority yet an
authoritative response and it's over
sort of like more ambiguity and that
just translated to frustration so I
think that a game that doesn't have the
ambiguous rules can still use a variety
of other strategies to get some of the
same things so making what's coming out
of this
the speed that ethical sphere which is
like most disruptive for players have to
think about other in the game the Magic
Circle sphere so we have to worry about
whether your action even though it's
permissible can be destructive on other
people's play experiences then that's
like an extra burden which normally in
more structured kinds of games we have
to worry about maybe maybe that's one of
the design yeah i would say that for
some players they were thinking about
and talked about them there the ethical
issues that i would say had to do the
Magic Circle and that was very much a
frustration but for some of the players
that was not a frustration that it was
just part of their awareness of the game
and the way they thought about the game
I would say that the manhood circle is
that that ethical domain becomes more in
the center of a player's focus in
pervasive games in games that put you in
the line between your everyday life and
the game under question let's so then
necessarily that necessarily that the
magics are putting the emphasis on that
may have to do more with it being a
pervasive game thing know if in the face
of ambiguity
like house rules that we live in an age
of recently graphic or Dana and so there
sometimes like you should come up with
your house I wonder if that arose Oh
certainly so um there was oh there was
definitely a lot of emergent play and
because this was a collaborative
storytelling enterprise which I didn't
really get into my presentation when
when gameplay emerges from the players
became masters have to respond a real
time and so we certainly came up with
things that were okay weren't okay on
the playa players always came up with
ideas that we never would have expected
also before we get too much further into
the Q&A I brought tangible artifacts and
I'd like to pass around if you want to
see them so this is one of the boxes and
then this is a sample map this is an
insignia and this is a one of the player
game packets that was handed out
you're doing one more about how the game
actually instantiated the story story
play into this just I know it's a big
subject sure um so my original concept
was to do a very tight adaptation and
throughout the research process it
became much more I became much more
interested in doing a loser adaptation
based on the themes and the setting and
space of the count of monte cristo at
the same time even though we as game
designers came to adopt that it's the
plot lines that we chose actually very
closely mirrored several of the fault
lines in the count of monte cristo the
characters you may have recognized our
abstractions of nantes and mercedes and
before and so on but it it was much more
trying to evoke the atmosphere and kind
of talk about the themes of ethics and
justice and injustice and law and
revenge that come up in exceed the whole
thing worked so it's either the players
kind of according to do not like men
rules were broken off when they got
disorganized and he said the first
question was
people change and what not a lot is what
do you think like I think what got clear
that they changed in the game but do you
think they changed like didn't you
reflect on their has a consistent to
what experience did you make an 80s do
you think it works or what what do you
think so I would say that my original
research question how how does one
design a game tonight change I think is
very broad and intentionally worded in
the sense that i'm i'm understanding
make change very specifically that it
can be anything from taking action to
reflection to awareness and so to bring
that to something i could actually
research i tried to focus it to how can
I design a game that engages players and
ethical game and I think that that's
what its ability did it was an exercise
research through design exercise on how
how I could what are some strategies to
think about that kind of game design
work and also what are some of the ways
that players respond to those kinds of
strategies and how do the players think
about ethics there are certainly
strategies that we use to encourage
ethical reflection which is gets a
little bit closer to changing but it
wasn't the motive was not set out to say
terrific to this and now you are now
something more info but more about like
trying to incorporate ethical reflection
as part of the game so the daily report
mechanic was really surprisingly
effective that players often wrote about
very nuanced and specific
ethical issues and I mean of course all
the players because this was research
they all knew what I they all you know
got my cookies farms and they knew what
I was going after but you know as you're
playing a game for seven days it was
still very surprising to see them
continue to think about these things and
say these things I would see that as
part of me
how would you reach into up great pride
in dollars
and
so for this game I had to be very clear
because of his research to clearly state
what my research goals were and I was
going to go about them and what I was
what kinds of research is what kind of
results I was asking for so I'm saying
things like you will be writing avoid
writing reports and emails to me talking
about what you did why are you doing oh
um I think that in a few tricking
whether i would or wouldn't do that i
think it would have to depend on the
context as in what what is the goal that
you're trying to accomplish what the
game is it around education or is it
around awareness or is it is it
something that you want to communicate a
message in a way that players come to
realize it and discuss like a process of
discovery so i think it certainly
depends i was wondering where the
thoughts and higher players negotiated
sort of our two personas
the characters that they took on and
what we advocate for themselves their
character especially when the line
between what's out of game what is
what's in game against Tabler I know in
line item airplane there's a what's
referred metagaming when you acquire in
game knowledge and out of the upsetting
and then use that to your advantage and
India say I wondering if similar
partners like that how human your
present yeah definitely so civilian was
designed for a really broad I I was
meaningful going into it that we were
targeting live-action role play players
or players who had well my experiences
pacifically but we wanted to thank them
we wanted to include am I can staff
undergraduate graduate students idiots
and because there was going to be such a
cadre of players I mean there's we were
going to get a lot of variety on those
issues of playing a character or playing
as my own self in the game and the
players who were planning character very
much thought of it that way they would
say well I was playing I've always
laying character I'll spoke to people in
character I went into games when I put
on my insignia and I came out game when
I got and other players didn't think
about it that way at all so I think for
some first avoids that concern and
others there wasn't similarly with
medicating so the players that I talked
to describe that as using out of King
knowledge right that you are not much
that you gain we're not in character and
use it there are few other things that
identify their similar to but not
exactly the same thing fidelity
once character which I talked about with
the da la da mistake that love that
dress that she was very much trying to
be have high fidelity to her character
as she understood it and there's also
fidelity to the game that somewhere is
very much believe I shouldn't use modern
technology because it wasn't available
in 1815 and other players extrapolated
that as well I can take notes and the
modern point the contemporary equivalent
is snapping a picture on my myself and
so different birds negotiate that
differently that did lead to some
tension from the game masters not having
a part in class rule yes you can use
email no you cannot use your cell phone
is that this is yes that is now and
Harvey that was you know a few of the
spectrum of possibilities with so large
but to get back to your original
question yeah I get into that a little
bit more in my thesis specifically
breaking down different identities that
I think players have make my games from
everyday life identity which is you know
us talking now and then the the
character identity which is the
character as it was created by the game
designers for quarter and this is partly
using to use the protective identity
where is me as a player having my
aspirations for this character and that
I think is what you would say it's
you're in character identity and then I
would also say there's a procedural
identity which is you as a player that
you as a player is different from you in
your life and then use a pair manifest
whatever you're playing games in it it
translates from game game because that
sort of it
I just thought I know we've talked a
little bit about Mia's work on a few
dating a Nevada Justin games to pick
your own enjoyment your own skill level
etc I'm curious if you thought about the
way the people negotiate with visuals
work she deserve a thank you as things
we invested our apology date but I guess
reflect on my own experience it seemed
like public before do it was changing
the game fit either what they were at
the time to do or what they had what
they would enjoy like there is the
question of you know you could only
contact people one time a day so if you
wanted to kind of the more time together
had to get in person or on email it's
like I started emailing people because
that was way too dusting the games yes
there is definitely a really good
example that related to that before to
after two what's one of the players
couldn't start playing until the second
day and so that was her first day in in
the game and from the beginning she
broke that before to rule because she
didn't get into town until after two and
she wrote in her report I broke this
rule already feel kind of mad but if I
didn't do that then I wouldn't be able
to play and so it was it was in a sense
adjusting adjusting the rules in order
to allow her to continue to engage with
this is uh I think
what I think hasn't received the names
with moral philosophy games but could
really stand for systematic right work
so I'll just wondering the degree to
which you saw this as sort of fitting
then no concept of the original state or
social contract lock in context you know
the idea of talk to us or state or
they're so mean Nietzschean possibility
or the public sphere and only you know
all these different ethical questions
that have been treated and all these
different way but which for some reason
you know like philosophers in this early
ethical side still not come to look at I
think a shame so I was just wondering
which you saw that is interesting though
that you might see this somehow either
cloud nagar inform your colors or maybe
even connect with some of these ideas
but the team back where he has
fundamentally comparable answered so
certainly um it was definitely something
I've been engaging with but because of
the scope of my project I chose
intentionally not engage too deeply with
more philosophy that a scholar that I
quoted earlier Miguel sacar does to a
very strong degree as do several other
scholars so I chose intentionally to let
civility be about what the players in
this particular test spoke about without
trying and the way that in in their
words I didn't necessarily want to be
categorizing them
how they responded so taking up that
point if I understand correctly so you
decided actively not to use social
dependent metric to find that who is
gaining the system Hannigan in other
words it's a trade-off between join us
and some sort of equal weight apply to
play for instance it everyone that for
little transponder and in the vicinity
of these with drop boxes you knew who
that time ok so this video and then b +
index that as their self-reported you
would have something that would be no
reference but if i'll understand even
saying chose actively not to do that
they want to be more of just a charmer
with person business as opposed to
understand with the system technically
worth of him yeah we chose not to do
that we did have we did in early drafts
of the game design you did design in a
lot of these checks checking mechanisms
to see are the players lying to us are
they actually doing what they say
they're doing but we as a game growing
alexia we decided that that wasn't what
we want to focus on and so we love that
the time span of your game seven days
around the clock is served at normal
time span for a game I think if you were
to take a hold of people and just have
games and games they would typically
name either things that are finishing
belen evening or are things that are
somewhat permanent MMOs things like that
and we're in an era now where the
permanent games are starting to have
players are having legal rights to
virtual property and that's very much
tied to Evans and so I'm wondering how
do you feel that your ethical domains
change along the x factor for very short
games games of your own language it's an
interesting question I think one that
would definitely fall into the further
questions whether it's not that I
haven't engaged a lot that I have
engaged a lot with so far a lot of thurs
did respond and talk about the seven day
period most of them expressed that they
felt it was too short for the type of
gameplay that we were asking for in
particular the deaddrop mechanism was
intended to be slow to simulate the slow
transfer of communication between people
in the early eighteen hundreds but that
coupled with the seven-day restriction
actually following slow and I think that
certainly affected the ethics of when
they felt like they could check their
bosses it was certainly a sense of well
if I have more time the maybe it would
go around stealing things for other
people because I've just come to me
later or if I had more time then I
wouldn't be checking in my box you know
at all hours because I feel this
pressure of the game